we managed to break records even for
ourselves that we never thought we would
do Avatar and its sequel are seriously
breathtaking at least for the cast but
you can't even fathom how difficult
filming underwater was creating worlds
from scratch with newly invented Tech
brought some of the biggest Feats the
film world has ever seen we just try to
be kind of true to what people loved
about the the first film number one we
are holding our breaths in anticipation
but that's definitely not what we're
talking about here Kate Winslet learned
to hold her breath for a super long time
Kate Winslet held her breath for seven
minutes like that is
actually it was 7 minutes and 14 seconds
but who's counting she did beat out Tom
Cruise who held his breath for six
minutes but if all this is impressing
you the Guinness Book of World Records
says that the record is 24 minutes and 3
seconds so it kinda puts Winslet to
shame but who are we to talk the average
is only 60 to 90 seconds number two it's
no secret that James Cameron continues
to reshape film forever when it came to
the original Avatar they were inventing
new technology all over the place many
people thought this couldn't be topped
in the sequel that all of the Innovation
had led to its success and Avatar 2
would fall flat but that isn't the case
at all James Cameron is still changing
the game with leading motion capture
techniques just this time he had to dive
deep into the water to make history
motion capture underwater had never been
done before this movie so as always
means though we know we're the guinea
pigs to create all of these stunning
scenes a gigantic 900 000 gallon
performance capture tank was built in
New Zealand so we're thrown in the deep
end with all this technology on us
number three there's no freedom in
freediving he had us working with like
world-renowned you know free divers the
cast did this for weeks to get
acclimated to not just the water but the
great depths at which they would be
shooting in nobody mentioned the
temperature but we bet it was freezing
too there's a consistent pattern of
water always being ice cold for shooting
it's kind of hard to keep giant pools of
liquid warm that's just the way of water
number four you'd think playing a child
would be a breeze compared to playing an
adult probably the most challenging for
me was to physically play a 14 year old
girl while Sigourney Weaver definitely
still has such a bubbly demeanor we
can't believe she's in her 70s we
definitely don't think she's 14 though
but thanks to the power of CGI and the
magic of training and memory she was
able to pull off a captivating
performance as the navi Kiri at least
from what we can tell from the trailer
so far she definitely found the age of
her character to be the biggest
challenge and we will gladly accept
whatever deus ex machina or forced plot
move they're spoon feeding us to bring
back Dr Grace Augustine Sigourney these
memories of actually being that young
were excruciating for her because I was
this tall that's 5 11. when I was 11.
number five the older folks in the cast
are proving they still got it we went
through uh training that included things
that I don't do Stephen Lang and
Sigourney Weaver found all the training
the parkour archery and Diving to be
intense I was determined that I could do
everything everyone else could number
six you wouldn't think flying would be
tough when they're filming feet from the
ground during the promo tour for the way
of water Zoe Saldana found the flying
sequences were the most rewarding this
time around because they were fun to
shoot but because of how the final
product turned out the way that we shot
it it was so different from how it
translated in the final sort of stab she
was just amazed at seeing what was
possible from what they were working
with which was basically just the
imagination honestly Saldana got to see
just 20 minutes of the way of water and
was moved to tears
number seven it's okay to be afraid
courage comes from facing those fears
Sam Worthington was also feeling this
dress of the underwater shoot saying
it's the hardest thing I've ever had to
do you're dealing with the restrictions
of freediving the constraints of motion
capture underwater and you're trying to
keep an emotional Journey going while we
imagine the rest of the cast was also
going through this Sam was the first one
to admit that on top of it all he was
innately struggling with his fear of not
making it out alive number eight we
don't know how these guys managed
without Duolingo let me hear this line
any scenes that involved the actors
speaking the navi language required
literally learning a whole new language
made up by Dr Paul frommer they speak
the same order
German which is i to the store go each
is
there over 400 Days of Duolingo practice
some
sound right here
zumladen yeah that's much better we
double checked with our trusty sidekick
Google too have you picked up a course
on Duolingo number nine try learning a
made-up language translating it back to
English and including an accent Zoe
Saldana had to single-handedly create
the navi accent in English since she had
the most lines in the movie which was
incredibly difficult and a lot of weight
on her shoulders I basically said Zoe
you get to establish what Nabi sounds
like everybody else just had to do their
best to copy her number 10 we don't take
too kindly to folks telling us what's
impossible around here shooting a bow
and arrow required training and was
difficult because the director asked
that Zoe Saldana flip her arm backwards
James Cameron was told what he wanted to
achieve was impossible so oh he walked
over and did the stunt himself to prove
it was totally possible what a sassy guy
honestly just 20 years ago even filming
Avatar was impossible the film crew had
to invent it all themselves so James
Cameron isn't the only one not to take
too kindly to the word impossible when
it comes to simple things like archery
number 11. the actors let animals be
their guides all of the navi movement
required a ton of physical work and this
was a process every day as anything that
looked even remotely human had to be
reshot we had to constantly be on them
every day about how they were fighting
they had coaches to get them moving
animal-like and I always wanted to do a
film where I was physically challenged
not only mentally this didn't just stop
with character movement but there was
also a dance choreographer number 12
doubling for multiple actors really
boosts the work required the stunt
doubles really had their work cut out
for them they were being flipped around
half hazardly and had to swing across
Vines like Tarzan the cool thing about
being a double in a CGI movie though is
you can take a lot more work on because
you don't need to have the exact same
look as the actor you're doubling number
13 James Cameron didn't trust the
actor's imaginations in order to capture
authentic performances James Cameron
took the actors into nature to engage
their sense memories being out in nature
with only half their clothes on roaming
through the jungles of Kauai would
certainly be an experience one wouldn't
forget your body reacts differently to
things once you've actually gone out and
done those things number 14 Sam
Worthington had double duty learning to
be Navi and Military Worthington had to
go through actual military training to
take part in the movie learning how to
use many different weapons in the
process he had to take Sam and teach
them how to be military as well number
15 making humans and Navi interact on
screen was excruciating anytime you had
both humans and avatars in a scene you
needed to film twice and overlay either
the humans or the navi this led to
slightly awkward interactions getting
off of dry land sure changed everything
for the cast and crew it sounds like the
way of water has really pushed the
actors in ways they never would have
expected are you excited to explore
something new in the world of Avatar let
us know in the comments and thanks for
hanging out with us here at the things